[Music]
imagine an alternate world where
dinosaurs evolved intelligence
comparable to a human's what might these
intelligent dinosaurs look like what
kind of technology culture and art might
they produce this speculative timeline
is the subject of dinosauroids a
world-building project conceptualized in
part by siam kozaman whose work you may
know from his sci-fi book all tomorrows
or from his speculative paleontology
book all yesterdays the latter of which
i've got a video on elsewhere in the
archive dinosauroids also comes from
simon roy an accomplished comic book
artist and writer who created much of
the art you'll see in this video these
two are outstanding creators and i have
links to where you can follow and
support them in this video's description
the dinosauroids project was born in
part out of cozamans and roy's
frustration with the work of
paleontologist dale russell who in 1982
created this concept of how a species
like atrodon might evolve into an
upright walking bipedal organism with
human-like intelligence while the
depiction has a retro vibe i find kind
of entertaining it's a pretty
old-fashioned and human-centric model of
an intelligent dinosaur so kozeman and
roy created their own more
scientifically viable models which don't
look much like humans but of all the
right ingredients for human-like
intelligence so for this entry into the
archive we'll explore the incredibly
detailed speculative world in history
roy and kozman created to go alongside
these new dinosaurs they even imagine
incredibly the art these creatures might
produce which we'll get into later in
the video
with that said let's begin
in the hypothetical alternate timeline
of dinosauroids there was no end
cretaceous asteroid impact nor did any
other cataclysm befall the non-avian
dinosaurs kozaman and roy theorized that
even without a mass extinction dinosaur
groups would have kept evolving into new
unfamiliar forms for now let's focus on
the dinosauroids themselves and explore
how the authors speculate they might
have first evolved the species they
imagine originated from troadon-like
ancestors the development of their
advanced intelligence and early use of
tools likely began slowly while the very
image of a bird-like species using
primitive spears might seem surprising
to some various modern birds in
particular crows which inspired the look
of dinosauroids are highly intelligent
and have indeed been seen using simple
tools and solving logical puzzles in
this experiment from the university of
auckland you can see a crow using stones
to gain access to submerged food showing
an impressive understanding of water
displacement in the process so the idea
of a bird-like dinosaur achieving
advanced intelligence through a similar
foundation isn't too outside the realm
of possibility
this image illustrates the two species
of intelligent dinosaurs on this
alternate earth both of which diverge
from a troidon-like ancestor while the
idea of multiple intelligent species
living on one planet at the same time
might seem surprising it's not too far
off from our own history with humans and
neanderthals the hypothetical scientific
designations of the two dinosauroids are
avisapians sorotheos and avasapian
statoricus and while both species make
frequent use of their beaks for tool use
they also seem to have complex hands
with dexterous fingers a feature that
could allow them to make use of delicate
tools and evolve brain function
analogous to a human's
aside from the dinosauroids the authors
designed an extensive ecosystem of
animals around the titular species while
most of these dinosaurs are descendants
of the manoraptorin group koziman and
roy also populated this hypothetical
world with various species of mammals
which have managed to grow into large
and sophisticated forms just like in our
time despite the presence of dinosaurs
due to the butterfly effect however
these mammals would of course be
different from the species we're
familiar with even if there are some
parallels one entertaining example of a
new species is the mega tapiris a large
herbivore that superficially resembles
an elephant due to the honing force of
convergent evolution a neat idea the
authors also imagine a variety of
mammalian carnivores that somewhat
resemble canine predators these mammals
are far from the largest organisms
patrolling this hypothetical world
however which still very much belongs to
the dinosaurs on the subject of
dinosaurs the authors wanted pterosaurs
to fill various niches since these
species were already in decline by the
time of the asteroid's impact however
kozaman and roy have imagined them
dwindling down to just a few subspecies
comparable to storks and other large
water birds
in terms of larger dinosaurs we have the
aptly named classification of the avid
titans massive lumbering herbivores that
are the largest new organisms on this
alternate earth another large species is
the bull bird a wary and dangerous
scavenger that stalks the plains of the
eurasian continent kozaman and roy
imagined that hunting bull birds was a
rite of passage for early dinosauroids
who needed to coordinate with each other
to take the beasts down some hunters
enlisted the help of jackal birds
hawk-like species that the dinosauroids
inventively managed to domesticate just
like early humans and the ancestor of
the modern dog but dinosauroids and
their domestic pets aren't the only
hunters on the plains these are the
tyranna raptors a species of
hypothetical theropods whose evolution
echoes that of none other than the
massive jawed tyrannosaurus rex this
dangerous predator is also known by the
dinosaurs as black thing and are the
largest predators in this imagined
dominion
in order to survive in this dangerous
world dinosauroids the creators
speculate have had to rely on their
technological cunning much like early
humans here you can see a dinosauroid
with a carved stone tool in its mouth
used for hunting at this point in the
speculative timeline most tribes of
dinosauroids are nomadic building
temporary structures while migrating for
protection from the elements one detail
i like is that these structures look a
lot like the nests of modern birds which
don't forget are also descendants of
theropods the authors imagine that the
dinosauroids do eventually form more
permanent village-like settlements which
are intriguingly still made up of nest
houses just more sturdy ones in these
more permanent societies early forms of
intricate cultural expression might
emerge like this young artist painting
on stretched animal skins using ground
up soil as well as other natural
pigments and a brush made from a wing
feather pretty clever still many
dinosaurs maintain migratory lifestyles
like these two individuals with a
domesticated form of bull bird mentioned
previously which is carrying their
various supplies other dinosauroids
travel light like this mountaineering
duo carrying weapons and travel gear
themselves curiously roy and koziman
mentioned their weapons are crafted from
bronze indicating the dinosauroids are
emerging into a new phase of
technological development many groups
also seem to equip themselves with
weaponized war masks wooden helmet-like
structures with obsidian blade edges to
improve the striking power of their
beaks while these masked warriors look
imposing the authors imagine these masks
while intimidating aren't actually the
most practical but dinosaurs society is
clearly becoming more technologically
proficient inventing armaments like a
unique spear-throwing device and
primitive bronze age sets of armor
clearly the dinosauroids are for better
or worse following our own path in many
ways
but warfare isn't the only aspect of
dinosauroid culture that kozman and roy
have fleshed out the two have also
created various images depicting what
paintings by dinosauroids might look
like
take for example this painting depicting
an eva titan family here the broad
impressionistic strokes that are a
trademark of the dinosauroid style are
reflective of how they use feathers to
apply paint or take this stylized
painting of a dinosauroid hunter
spearing some four-legged mammal an
image which reminds me of early cave
paintings are human ancestors created
even more stylized we have a mural of a
warrior confronting a spirit creature
here you can see elements of myths and
legends sneaking their way into the art
just as was the case with human cultural
development the dangerous predatory
black thing gets a similar treatment
with the organism's mouth and horns
exaggerated in the artist's recreation
reflecting the parts of the animal that
stood out the most to the dinosauroid
creator
and beyond paintings perhaps the
dinosauroids might have also told spoken
stories and their own bird-like
languages here you can see a fireside
chat between an elder and several
hatchlings kozaman and roy imagine this
storyteller is weaving tales of spirits
and other worlds in particular a legend
of a sky god which resembles a flying
pterosaur what a creative level of world
building beyond these early societies
who knows what the future might have
held for a species like the dinosauroids
perhaps their technology would continue
to develop like this hypothetical sketch
of a more heavily armored warrior which
almost resembles a knight and who knows
perhaps long into the hypothetical
future this species might even develop
the technology necessary to become a
space-faring civilization it's a pretty
interesting concept although not one
kosman and roy have said they've pursued
seriously still the hypothetical future
of the dinosauroids seems full of
endless potential although we've reached
the end of our exploration for this
particular video if you like this world
please consider supporting roy and
kozmin by patronizing their other works
and social media which as always you can
find in the links below and if you like
this video i have others covering the
speculative work of cm kozumin elsewhere
in the archive also thanks for watching
if you enjoyed this entry please lend
your support and like subscribe and hit
the notification icon to stay up to date
on all things curious see you in the
next video
i